mais bon Philippe c'est clair ça à
l'Orient ça pour qu'il ait une érection
faut lui dire mesdames et messieurs
bonsoir
pourquoi
cette année tu rentres par là alors que
la dernière tu rentrais par là tu
préfères rentrer à gauche cette année je
sais pas pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
une revue de presse particulière Thierry
leur n'est plus à la rigolade ou est
passé Cécilia s'inquiète la presse
Cécilia première dame de France à temps
partiel
dernier apparition publique enterrement
de Jacques Martin
manifestation sponsorisée par Alain
Afflelou
Cécilia est-elle vraiment partie si l'on
en croise cette info de la page santé de
match l'orgasme est bon pour la migraine
oui oui
pourquoi tout quitter première dame de
France un métier super Bernadette s'est
éclaté comme ce jour où elle a pu
embrasser Rostropovitch mort
un métier
un métier sans SAS mercredi par exemple
tu pouvais faire un tour de 4x4 de nuit
avec Poutine
l'inventeur des cocktails au Pologne
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même plus rigolo que de
chanter la pêche aux moules avec un
animateur télé
le week-end dernier Cécilia vous avez
loupé un moment magique les vestiaires
de Cardiff votre mari en costume cravate
entouré de rugbyman en slip
en slip à côté du président ça et la
lettre de Guy Moquet
la Coupe du monde ils vont s'en souvenir
vous auriez pu voir Chabal en vrai
Cécilia Chabal l'innocence brut qui
cette semaine encore demandé à ses
camarades pourquoi lui quand il se
caresse la [ __ ] avec un ballon ça lui
fait rien
après vous avez loupé le resto avec
Massias et sa nouvelle chanson ah
qu'elles sont jolies les filles de mon
pays mais maintenant quand elles
viennent ici il faut qu'elle fasse un
test ADN
au dessert Hortefeu est arrivé avec une
nouvelle idée pour stopper les
sans-papiers un truc essayant Suisse
cette semaine le Taser tu les
électrocutes Sevran voulait leur couper
la [ __ ] une idée chasse l'autre
et puis avant de partir Nicolas a
raconté son histoire préférée celle de
Gilbert Montagné le soir de la victoire
quand il pense soutenir ses collègues
royales
ne partez pas Cécilia je vous ai trouvé
un coach un faiseur de stars un magicien
Dominique bessenard c'est lui qui
s'occupe de Ségolène bah c'est golem
c'est le métamorphose la chrysalide est
devenue papillon c'est dans sa coiffure
son côté Bécassine la Halle aux
vêtements tout ça c'est dit stop quand
elle était députée son sac à main
c'était un attachéquage
t'imagines SOS médecins à l'Assemblée
nationale
passons aujourd'hui c'est gaufres
qu'elle trouve quelqu'un à Julien dress
c'est pas possible tu quittes pas
culbuto pour aller avec landruche
mon rêve c'est un ticket Ségolène
Toretto mais bon Philippe c'est clair ça
Lorient ça pour qu'il ait une réaction
faut lui dire mesdames et messieurs
bonsoir
c'est Sylvia ma puce et quand tu veux ou
tu veux la porte est ouverte tu
m'appelles aller à la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bon comme ça
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu